next we have justin antonio pillai he is
the he serves as the counselor to
Secretary penny Pritzker within the
delegated duties of the undersecretary
for economic affairs he leads the
economics and statistics administration
which includes the office of the chief
economist also the Census Bureau and the
bureau of economic analysis he serves as
a senior adviser to the Secretary on a
wide range of issues including tax
digital economy and data policy issues
he's here today to speak about making
our data your data Alan thanks very much
and I feel duty-bound to say especially
to a group like this of real data
scientists and geniuses that I'm from
the government and i'm here to help so
let me start with a couple things i hope
your eyes didn't glaze over too much
when I say I'm from the economic and
statistics administration in fact this
is one of the few audiences I've spoken
to lately that you got a little bit
excited so that really made my morning
i'm going to start is it is it too loud
I apologize minimum of this note I'm
going to start an honor of Stephen
Wolfram and his role and and this
organization's role in the general area
of mathematics with a quick story
because I think it illustrates the way
we are thinking about our role and the
challenges we face on big public
problems and how we're thinking about it
in a very humble way in terms of what
we've done in the government and I'll
reemphasize humble because I know in
this group you're working in a very
advanced way on some of these challenges
so let me ask this to start how many of
you know one of the biggest most famous
mathematical problems that was the
subject of the clay Institute's
challenge that was actually solved who
can who can answer that oh I'm shocked I
thought I would get a whole room full of
answers okay so who raised their hand
no no but good guess anybody else nope
you got it poink arrays conjecture okay
so let me let me talk a little bit about
on repoint Caray and his famous point
correia gesture and I'm believe me I'm
not going to speak about it what the
actual conjecture is about but it's an
interesting story that I think is worth
highlighting so pointer a conceived his
conjecture in 1904 you ought to read
about it and the the actual conjecture
was an offhand remark at the end of a
64-page paper and for 100 years it
remained one of mathematics most
fundamentally difficult problems
especially when it came to solving it in
four dimensions solving the problem when
it came to four-dimensional challenges
and then in 2002 an anonymous paper came
out initially that was just posted on
the internet in a couple of specific
spots that without even if I remember
correctly and Steven you tell me if I'm
wrong it didn't even mention poink
arrays conjecture and by the way I'm
going to miss pronounce his name several
times the next few minutes of bear with
me but it turned out he'd sold the
conjecture in an anonymous set of
posting that was confirmed over the next
two years and the clan stitute had
actually put up a 1 million dollar prize
and the same gentleman grigori perelman
when he solved it he got the 1 million
dollar prize and was awarded the Fields
Medal which got almost no attention
outside the mathematics community but
you know what got a whole bunch of
attention outside the mathematics
community when he turned it down he
turned down a million dollars and the
Fields Medal because he wasn't
interested in it and he's semi
disappeared he went on one series of
lectures and disappeared from the face
of the earth is a really fascinating set
of coverage about him ok so now why did
I talk about this because I am semi
fascinate
with mathematical history not because I
understand the math but because I love
the idea of an entire community of
really advanced geniuses just publicly
posting their solutions to problems some
of which have very little practical
applicability making them known
challenging the community to validate or
invalidate them and then moving on to
the next challenge I love the idea that
this challenge was posted publicly for
the world and that an unknown relatively
unknown mathematician from Russia posted
the solution having done the work in
isolation much as Newton did when he was
developing many of his theories posted
his theory becomes an incredibly famous
mathematician and just disappears
essentially from public life I love it
because that's kind of the way we are
thinking about data in our humble way in
the government which is we know that we
do not know all the ways that our data
could be used and we have incredible
incredible data that I will talk about
we know that we have to do more to
curate it and get it available to user
groups and and experts like yourself and
so we're starting that and I will tell
you what we've been doing and we know
that if we challenge the communities and
make some of these data available which
we're working on and we think about
creative ways that we get you interested
in these datasets that you all are going
to solve some public problems that we
didn't conceive or couldn't have known
of and there are several communities
including Wolfram and some other ones
that are challenging challenging their
own user groups of experts and data
scientists to just look at a problem and
tell us what the solution is that's
really interesting that's the kind of
leverage we need in the government
because we don't know all of the
vertical problems all of the issues that
could be solved but we do know we have
data I was looking at one of the
communities and I was talking about it
with steven this morning and that has
just posted some public data sets and
had the community engage on them and
it's fascinating when you read them
how people have engaged with data and
they had everything from an analysis of
the world's highest mountains to a set
of statistical and other algorithmic
analyses around data relating to plane
crashes since 1908 and that's the kind
of thing where you don't know where
we're going to go but it has real real
potential for us in terms of where we're
hoping to go so let me start by saying
our overall goal as we've said it in
terms of a North Star on the federal
government layout level with respect to
data is to democratize our data to make
it available to you to make it available
to more nonprofits charities small and
medium-sized entities and there are a
lot of challenges that are actually
associated with that and if you don't
mind I will start by saying why we at
commerce and how myself I have been
looking at this particular challenge so
let me start with myself so I my
training by way of background is as a
lawyer and I started my career
representing small and medium size and
you know fighting for small and
medium-sized companies around the
country and I spent an incredible amount
of time also donating legal services
including setting up clinics and others
for those who couldn't afford my legal
services and we spent I spent a thousand
hours one year representing those all
over our country who cannot afford the
services of a paid lawyer and it brought
me I'll give you observations from both
on the small and medium sized entities
those that are growing around the
country they are some of the best of
what America has to offer and I assure
you you know them they're focused on
their communities they're trying to grow
the lead executives care deeply about
their people and how they get there they
often faced razor thin margins
violations of their financial covenants
by their lenders and skating along those
issues and they were deeply focused on
their own number
at the same time I worked with a lot of
bigger companies and I saw what the what
you all bring to the execution of your
company's missions how even more junior
you know not expert data scientists can
materially advance a mission and can get
your company's thinking about very
difficult issues using data instead of
using your gut and that is a very was a
very very stark lesson to me at the same
time I was out regularly working as I've
told you with those in our society who
had very very little so in a trial
setting for example would I which I had
access to and worked with regularly when
I was representing and working with very
large companies who are thinking about
going to trial over dollars or money or
an injunction I knew that there was an
entire industry that is driven off of
data that the Department of Commerce
provides in terms of demographic data
and others in the jury consultant world
that would bring that data to companies
to help them make sure they're jury pool
was was prepared the right way for their
particular case and yet when I was
representing and I know this throughout
when you have public defenders legal aid
dealing with life and death when they're
dealing with 20 years in prison and when
you're looking to pick a jury you have
none of that data at your fingertips
none of it and so the way we have been
thinking about the issues of data is one
that parallels very very closely broadly
the conversations that are going on
around the country on income inequality
are you all generally familiar with the
discussion on income inequality and the
idea almost starts from when you think
about income inequality from quotes that
go back to Plutarch where an imbalance
between the rich and poor is the oldest
and most fatal elements ailments of all
Republic
right the idea that you have to think
about the rich and poor together what we
have seen when we look at how our data
is accessed directly is that there are
sophisticated users that when we make
our data available use it even more but
we have not seen an uptick in direct
access and use by charities nonprofits
and small and medium sized entities that
said I we think of another famous quote
when I say Democrat democracy rests upon
two pillars one the principle that all
men and women are equally entitled to
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness and the other that the
conviction that such equal opportunity
will most advanced civilization so we
are approaching data and we're trying to
drive towards a principle that with
respect to data we have to think about
the problem in the same way as one
thinks of income inequality we have to
do basic things treating our data as a
critical asset looking to tools that
will make our data more available and
i'll talk about some of those datasets
publicizing which of those datasets
might be most useful to you and your
communities and why and trying to bring
simple last-mile tools that will solve
vertical simple problems that can be
scalable i'll give you the simple
example when I see and I engage with big
financial institutions and
multinationals and hedge funds I see
very very deep use of my demographic
data and when you come if you were to
say you're a hedge fund manager that's
actually getting access to our data
versus a smaller office that's not
looking at those kinds of trends you see
the likelihood that the big actor who
has regular access and sophisticated
access to our data is much more likely
to have a higher return than the one who
isn't that's the kind of ways we're
thinking about it so I'm going to talk a
little bit more specifically now about
what the data is that I
you to look at and how we're thinking
about the problem but I don't want to
bury the lead because the real reason
I'm here is to paraphrase President
Obama when he spoke at South by
Southwest last year the reason I'm
really here is to recruit all of you we
need your help we need your help outside
the government and we need your help
inside the government we know that we
can make data public we know that we can
issue challenges we know that we can
identify public problems we know that we
can think about how the data might be
used to solve the public problems but we
need you to actually help us do it and
we need you on some of our teams inside
the federal government actually working
directly with us to think through the
problems so luckily we have a president
that has been very very focused on
public data from day one in fact on his
first day in office the president
launched the open government initiative
and ordered all federal agency heads to
make our data as open and available as
possible this was really really
meaningful he also established the first
ever White House chief technology
officer to promote a more open and
tech-savvy government he appointed
Aneesh Chopra who's right here in DC
followed by Todd Park and now Meghan
Smith to try and drive our thought
processes around technology and data in
a more Silicon Valley Northern Virginia
and New York kind of way the president
also went on to appoint the first White
House chief data scientist gja Patel
brought on board people like Jen Palka
with Code for America who were thinking
about these issues in a much more subtle
way and he launched some critical tools
that are probably not well known outside
the government but that have been really
important to us to advance the data
mission as I'll talk about and that
included launching a presidential
innovation Fellows program to bring and
attract some talent into the government
even for one year stints he built a u.s.
digital service which is working very
very hard to help us clean and get our
data out in
and teach how to use api's and the 18f
program which serves as a central
clearinghouse for us to actually work
directly with some of our best around
the government i also have had the
benefit and we've had the benefit of
commerce of working with and having a
leader like secretary Pritzker who
started her career as an entrepreneur
and actually used our Commerce
demographic data sets to make decisions
she has known from the very beginning
has been directing us think about ways
that we can enable growth that we can
get to charities and nonprofits to get
our data out because we have more
interesting data than a lot of the other
agencies then you might be thinking
about so let me let me start there what
exactly is in the Department of Commerce
and let me say as I mentioned a couple
times I didn't have great depth of
knowledge of the what commerce head and
I have not been in the government more
than the last three years but we have
any i can tell you data from each of
these we have the patent and trademark
office that has incredible data about
patent applications and grants and
they're actually making it available
both in bulk and making it available on
api's we have the international trade
administration which is a core
participant and all of our trade
negotiations but has very fine import
export data that we make available for
free we have the national oceanic and
atmospheric administration NOAA that has
incredible incredible data available on
the ocean and endangered species and of
course includes the National Weather
Service which has massive massive
datasets and a lot of very important
environmental public problems that we're
trying to solve we have the Census
Bureau and the Bureau of Economic
Analysis inside the my Bureau the
economic and statistics administration
census as you know collects incredible
and distributes incredible demographic
data through things like the American
Community Survey and the American
population survey and the decennial and
with the bureau of economic analysis is
one of the main course statistical
agencies on producing GDP
our goal has been to try and educate and
get these data sets out and to think
about ways that we can do it that are
more innovative so let me tell you how
we've been doing it the first is that we
built a team we had to bring some top
talent into government and we started by
building an internal team led by our
current chief data scientist Jeff Chan
who is one of really a really thoughtful
group of leading data scientists in the
government who are teaching us how do
you actually curate our datasets clean
them as quickly as we can and get them
out with some analysis around them so
that they can actually be used on a
quick aside let me tell you a quick
story about Jeff because I think it
illustrates you know why he was the
right person for us to bring into
government he Jeff also happens to be a
photographer and he wanted to take a
picture of the Milky Way he is fancier
equipment than i do but it's not like
you know the fanciest on earth so he to
solve the problem of where should i go
to take this photograph where i have the
highest likelihood of getting a picture
of the Milky Way he pulled NOAA weather
data including luminescence data that
they have publicly available for free he
pulled data from some national parks he
pulled demographic information from
census and he ran some basic analysis to
see where in the general area he should
go to take a picture and he found that
there is a place in a field in the
middle of the shenandoah national park
that is spot-on perfect and he took the
picture and it's amazing and it's on our
website but that goes to show you like
there are a number of different problems
when you actually know our datasets and
you know what you might be able to do
with them you might be able to solve
some absolutely interesting amazing
problems down the line so and part of
part of what we did was also create an
advisory committee of external data
experts who have been advising us but I
started with a plea to join our team and
I will repeat it here we are hiring we
need developers and we need data
scientists to join our team
once we started doing the things that
I'll talk about which is educating about
what data science is and showing our own
bureaus what you can do with it the
demand for our own internal services has
really skyrocketed second thing we're
doing in addition to building the team
is making our data more consumable that
means we are looking at data sets that
haven't been accessible publicly in a
while and trying to get them up we're
trying to curate them and put some data
sets up in a clean form that are in bulk
format and we're looking a lot more to
use to build api's and seed source
libraries they can let you access them
well let me say I went to meetings three
years ago in the government where you
would say the term API and nobody knew
what you were talking about seriously
and now I can go to almost any meeting
at the senior level at the political
level with non-technical people and they
and you say what API means at what it
what it is and they know what it is that
is an absolutely amazing leap forward
and it shows that if you set a real
priority around data and what you can do
with it you can really really advance
the bowl relatively quickly we're also
seeding some public libraries in Python
and are how many of you know what r is
okay thank God I asked the right
question ok so we're seating some public
libraries in our in Python to try and
make our data that's available from say
our economic bureaus and our demographic
data more easily available to the expert
user groups and again we're not we're
humble about this we're going to see the
library we're going to put some out
there that have some interesting use
cases and our goal is to highlight those
libraries and have you build around them
with more use cases the third thing
we're doing is in addition to building
our internal team and trying to curate
our own data has been to ask for help
like I've done today on identifying and
helping us solve on a last mile so that
we can have access to our data in a way
that's meaningful once again we've done
this in a couple of different ways we've
sponsored some hackathons
we've highlighted our data to a number
of different groups and ask them look at
this and look at ways we might solve
public problems we've recently issued a
call to look at some specific data sets
to build specific tools from those that
build business intelligence tools and
otherwise that would be publicly
available that would help certain user
groups actually access our data more are
these going to be successful are these
going to actually drive use of our data
we hope so but again once we release the
tools we need experts and leaders like
you to actually tell us if we got it
right give us some feedback on them and
help publicize them as we get them out
but it has had some interesting benefits
and I mean them from a very public way
so one of the things we created and just
the last year was an API that makes
income data available it's called Midas
making income data available as a
service you should look it up but one of
our goals with income data was of course
to make income data available for
companies to look and look
demographically and geographically
around income data but we also wanted
that income data to be used by data
scientists and others to identify
problems with pay gaps to help
nonprofits and charities advocate better
for where there are pay graphs at bay
gaps and John a gender basis or
otherwise and help those groups actually
advocate for themselves using data so
this is again one of those things that
we are trying to tackle in in as as
aggressive away as possible so I'll
issue the same call to you as we've been
issuing all over the country which is
look at our data sets look at some ways
that we might help address this issue of
data inequality and look at some ways in
which we might solve some public
problems with your help using our data
now I mentioned that one of the things
we've been doing is looking directly at
who in fact is accessing our data and
when we did that even a
the Census Bureau we found of the top
100 direct accessors now again a lot of
our data ends up being processed and
resold but a very significant chunk of
them were consulting firms including
especially in the real estate space and
just as I mentioned earlier we have no
problem with that in fact we like the
fact that consultants are using our data
we like the fact that companies
multinationals and others are using our
data we want more of that there's no
problem with that but the same time if
we really want to expand the universe of
public data users and get more of these
other institutions to use them and think
about them for public problems we really
can't do that on our own and so the way
we have been doing it is to issue
challenges like we did here today to
look at some of these datasets and the
first question I get asked is okay which
particular data sets which data said
should we be looking at there are a
number of different places in the
federal government where data sets have
been aggregated and a lot of them get
criticism for various different reasons
so one of the things we're doing in
connection with my speech here today is
we're releasing the first of a curated
list of data sets on our website so if
you look at our blog today we will be
posting or may have posted very very
much today a set of 20 or so data sets
that we think are high value some of
which are in both some of which are an
API that we would like you to look at
but we're not going to stop this by just
posting a PDF of a set of data sets
we're going to start a conversation on
github and we would like the community
like yours to look at this and we're
going to ask our own teams at Commerce
and elsewhere in the government to help
us identify high-value data sets and
what they can be used for and engage
bless you and engage on that community
in that community but we would also like
you and others who are using our data
who have identified high-value data sets
to share that knowledge with with the
broader community to use our repository
as
place to have a more intelligent
thoughtful nuanced discussion about
high-value data sets and how they might
be used so please look for our link and
our github link and take this
opportunity to help us highlight and
identify high-value data sets that can
be used for public good and and when I
when I identify them you'll wonder when
you see the list you'll identity will
figure out quickly while we've
identified them very very fine data sets
that include demographic data from the
Census department including on
population we have a number of different
weather related data sets that includes
weather patterns climate change and
other energy efficiency data on
international business in manufacturing
that we think would be very valuable
data on patented products and medicines
and economic trends all of them are very
high value if you think about them in
the right way and let me get to some
specific use cases that we're thinking
about but that again we don't want to
design every solution we want help in
trying to figure out how to do it right
one of the ones that we've seen that was
interesting is census releases some very
fine import export data araya arranged
by HS code and so when I've engaged with
companies I've seen there are importers
that when they're about to send a
product out or importers who are buying
a product or exporter sending the
product out there are even small and
medium sized entities that access our
data sets and they use it to see who
where are their competitors buying or
selling buying to buying from or selling
to so if you have a door for if you're
trying to buy a door frame you can
literally go on our data sets and see
where the highest level of imports the
door frames and where people are selling
door frames to that is exactly the kind
of use case we want out of our import
export data sets let's say that you're a
small or medium manufacturer distributor
just right here in Richmond or down in
Richmond or somewhere near here we would
like you to be looking at the
International Trade administration's
api's which we highlight because they'll
tell you
about the country and industry reports
produced by leading trade experts that
provide for trade opportunities to a
number of different countries and there
are many others but again we're hoping
that by challenging and putting these
data sets out that are curated and
engaging specifically we'll get to some
use cases that are simple usable and
scalable scalable because when we come
out down to it i'll tell you three
things that i would like and that we
would like in the short term for our own
us companies manufacturers and
distributors we want solutions that will
allow them to use our demographic data
to grow their companies and hire more
people and accomplish their missions we
want nonprofits to be able to use our
demographic and economic data to be
driving their services and their
advocacy in a more data-driven way we
want charities to be able to fundraise
in a finer more thoughtful way using
some of our income and our demographic
data and I want a public defender and a
legal aid or a legal services provider
who's spending by the way a lot of their
time as social service providers in the
community they are trying they care
often about where their clients not only
whether they're going to be convicted
but they care where they're eating and
sleeping and how their families are
doing and they're trying to make a case
and gather the facts I want them to have
tools that that let them easily and on
the moment of a jury selection
understand the demographic makeup of a
jury pool in the same way that companies
do every day because when these things
happen we will start to have made some
progress on democratizing our data and
at the same time we're going to be
looking for for more expert communities
to help us as we put our data sets up
solve the biggest public problems we
have and you can talk about them from an
environmental approach with protecting
our oceans helping identify when there's
been overfishing helping to protect
endangered species by identifying
through satellite imagery and
when those have been affected and you
can have similar benefits from some of
the massive data streams that will be
coming from the census in the connection
with the next 2020 census so I'll start
where I end where I started which is I
really appreciate and we have really
appreciated the opportunity to engage
with a community like yours to talk
about what we're doing to highlight some
of these data sets to challenge and have
you help us on this journey I don't
think that we're getting everything
right I'm not even sure that we've
identified exactly the right data sets
or that we're going about the right way
and curating and getting them out we
need help we need advice but given the
size of the data sets we have the areas
that we cover the overall government
effort that's being put into trying to
get these data sets out so that you
might inspire solutions just like
grigori perelman did when he just solved
the math problem on its own it's been
absolutely critical for us to continue
to try and address data inequality by
trying to do everything we can and it's
just like justice Marshall said I
challenge anyone to say that equality is
not a goal worth fighting for that's
really what we're at and we're going to
have to do it on a bunch of different
fronts if we're actually going to
advance this really really important
goal over the long term of addressing
data inequality so thank you for your
time and I'm happy to take any questions
you